(générique)
---
-Bonjour.
Bienvenue au Parlement européen
pour un nouveau numéro
d'"Europe hebdo".
Direction Ceuta, une enclave
espagnole au nord du Maroc
et une porte d'entrée
de l'Afrique vers l'Europe.
350 jeunes hommes venus
d'Afrique subsaharienne
ont franchi,
il y a quelques jours,
la double clôture de 6 mètres
de haut et 8 kilomètres de long.
Très organisés, ils sont plus
d'un millier depuis janvier
à avoir escaladé le barbelé
ou fracassé certains accès
avec des marteaux.
D'autres passages en force
spectaculaires
ont aussi eu lieu en octobre 2014
à Melilla,
autre territoire espagnol.
Dans cette émission,
j'accueille trois eurodéputés,
Inés Ayala Sender,
bonjour. Vous êtes députée
européenne, espagnole,
du groupe des socialistes
démocrates.
Vous êtes aussi présidente
de la délégation
pour les relations
avec les pays du Maghreb,
merci d'être venue.
Philippe Juvin,
vous êtes eurodéputé, français,
du parti populaire européen,
monsieur Europe,
chez les Républicains, en France,
membre de la commission des Affaires
étrangères au Parlement européen.
Merci d'être venu.
Enfin, Nathalie Griesbeck.
Vous êtes eurodéputée du groupe
de l'alliance des démocrates
et libéraux pour l'Europe.
En France, vous avez été élue
sous les couleurs du MoDem.
Avant de débattre : les images.
Depuis des mois, la route
de l'Espagne était fermée.
En quelques jours,
plus de 800 personnes
ont forcé cette route
à la frontière de Ceuta,
au nord du Maroc. On regarde
et on réagit juste après.
-Mission accomplie.
Celui-ci laisse éclater sa joie.
Il est passé en Europe.
(cris de joie)
La fin d'un périple
qui a duré plusieurs semaines,
ceux-là se mettent carrément
à genoux et remercient le Bon Dieu.
-Merci beaucoup.
-C'est Dieu !
-Il est quatre heures du matin,
dans les rues de Ceuta,
l'enclave espagnole au Maroc,
ce groupe de 350 jeunes hommes,
venus d'Afrique subsaharienne,
a réussi à franchir
la double clôture
de 6 mètres de haut
et 8 kilomètres de long.
Une dizaine d'entre eux a été
blessée en escaladant le grillage,
mais après plusieurs semaines
de voyage
et pour certains,
plusieurs échecs,
ce jour-là, la joie
est au rendez-vous.
-Ouais, putain ! Ouais !
(cris de joie)
-Ils ont mis un pied en Europe.
C'est le 2nd passage en force
de la frontière en trois jours.
---
Il y a deux semaines,
près de 500 hommes
ont réussi aussi
à gagner Ceuta.
Le centre d'accueil des migrants
est saturé et les autorités
craignent que la situation devienne
de plus en plus critique.
-Silence ! Silence !
-Silence.
(cris de joie)
-Il y a ceux qui passent,
il y a ceux qui attendent de passer.
Belyounech, une commune rurale
au Maroc.
La forêt
de Douarbirou pas très loin
de l'enclave espagnole.
Ici, se cachent
des migrants subsahariens.
Leurs compagnons de route
sont parvenus à franchir
la haute barrière
séparant l'enclave
espagnole du Maroc.
Youssouf et Aminou ont échoué.
Ils disent se débrouiller
comme ils peuvent
au Maroc,
même si c'est difficile.
Ils gardent l'espoir de gagner
l'Eldorado européen.
-On vit un peu difficilement.
Juste parce qu'on recherche
l'Europe,
un passage pour l'Europe,
avoir des conditions de vie
meilleures,
parce qu'elle me plaît pas la vie,
la vie au Maroc, elle me plaît pas.
C'est difficile, on ne peut pas
avoir un travail,
je ne peux pas travailler.
-On n'a pas où dormir.
-Voilà, on n'a pas d'habitat.
-Plusieurs fois.
-Combien de fois ?
-Trois fois,
au moins trois fois déjà.
-Moi, j'ai été chopé
au moins quatre ou cinq fois.
Mais on se bat pour pouvoir
avoir ce qu'on peut,
pour pouvoir aider nos familles.
Nous, on connaît les positions
de nos familles.
Nous, on connaît comment
nos familles vivent au pays,
c'est pas facile.
-Ici, la surveillance
de la seule frontière
terrestre
entre le continent africain
et l'Union Européenne relève
de la responsabilité
de l'Espagne et du Maroc.
Mais le royaume chérifien,
en froid avec Bruxelles, au sujet
d'un accord de libre-échange
a récemment menacé à demi-mots
de relâcher son contrôle.
Un avertissement explicite :
la collaboration dans le domaine
de l'immigration
irrégulière est liée
à la satisfaction
de certaines attentes du Maroc.
-Reportage à Ceuta
et près de Ceuta.
Inés Ayala Sender,
question simple, est-ce que le Maroc
joue les migrants
contre l'Union Européenne ?
-Je pense que ce n'est pas
exactement cette situation.
Je pense que la position
de l'immigration
par rapport
à l'Union Européenne
est beaucoup plus ample,
et on a vu qu'il y a le tampon
en Turquie avec l'accord turc.
Et c'est normal
que d'autres partenaires,
qui sont des partenaires
privilégiés avec l'Europe,
qui ont fait
leur travail en bilatéral,
Espagne-Maroc,
dans les années plus dures,
où on ne reconnaissait pas
toute la pression des migrations
dans le Sud
comme une affaire européenne,
on a dû attendre que les migrants
viennent presque à Berlin
pour que ce soit le cas.
C'est normal que maintenant,
il y ait une grande sensibilisation,
et en plus, avec un partenaire
spécial, comme l'est le Maroc,
par rapport à d'autres accords,
à d'autres politiques,
qui font partie, comment dire,
de la relation...
-Le Maroc fait le job, quoi.
-Voilà. Il a fait son travail.
-Philippe Juvin, le Maroc
avait prévenu, à la décision
de la cour de justice
de l'Union Européenne
d'exclure le Sahara occidental
d'un accord agricole
avec l'Union Européenne
et le Maroc,
ça avait suscité les menaces
implicites de Rabat.
"Si vous ne reconnaissez pas
la marocanité du Sahara occidental,
"je vous lâche les migrants ?"
-On vient de voir
un avertissement explicite.
Il faut être aveugle
pour ne pas comprendre.
Il y a eu autant de passages
de migrants en quelques jours
que dans toute l'année 2016
sur cette frontière.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie ?
Probablement que le Maroc
a ouvert la porte,
laissé passer des migrants
pour montrer aux Européens
qu'il fallait être conciliants
dans les accords.
Le Maroc a fait
de la politique avec des malheureux.
Il faut en tirer les conséquences.
L'Europe a besoin du Maroc,
très évidemment,
on sait ce que devient
la partie nord de l'Afrique
s'il n'y a pas d'Etat organisé
en matière d'immigration,
donc nous avons intérêt
à ce que le Maroc soit
un partenaire fiable.
Mais j'ose rappeler quand même,
que le Maroc
a aussi beaucoup besoin de l'Europe.
La majorité de ses relations
commerciales est avec l'Union.
Je dis aux Marocains :
"Ne jouez pas avec le feu".
-C'est un avertissement explicite,
Nathalie Griesbeck ?
-Je suis allée l'année dernière
voir, justement,
le mur et la double barrière
à Ceuta et Melilla pour discuter
avec les autorités marocaines
et espagnoles,
puisqu'il s'agit
d'une frontière extérieure
de l'Europe et comme l'a dit
ma collègue,
ce qui se passe ici,
c'est ce qui peut se passer
à toutes les frontières
extérieures de l'UE.
Et on voit bien
que la politique migratoire,
c'est un pan de la politique
qui se discute dans le dialogue
politique en général.
-EN GENERAL.
-Si on veut
que l'Europe retrouve ses bases,
on doit organiser les choses
aux frontières, dialoguer,
mais on doit aussi accentuer
la coopération...
(elle hésite)
..par les biais
qui ont été utilisés ici,
la décision de justice,
mais ça ne change rien
au fait qu'il n'y a pas
une seule réponse
et que les murs ne sont pas,
de loin, les seules réponses,
les réponses sont le dialogue
politique, la coopération,
l'aide au développement,
et puis la distinction aussi
entre les réfugiés
et les migrants économiques,
parce que dans votre reportage,
on explique
qu'ils crient et sont contents
d'atteindre l'Eldorado,
l'Europe n'est pas
l'Eldorado que des vendeurs
de passage ont pu leur dire.
Je pense qu'il est important
pour nous, les Européens,
tous les Européens,
de discuter avec les autorités
des Etats qui sont
en bordure des pays membres
de l'Union Européenne.
C'est fondamental.
-C'est un problème humanitaire,
de police et géopolitique.
Un rapport parlementaire en France
disait que l'Europe regardait trop
à l'Est et pas assez au Sud.
Faut-il
redynamiser cette coopération
avec les pays du Maghreb ?
-Oui, tout à fait.
-Et les pays africains ?
-Justement,
c'est un des éléments
qu'en tant que présidente
de la délégation parlementaire...
Justement, c'est sur cela
qu'on veut travailler,
on a parlé, hier même,
avec la commission,
dans les affaires de migration
et de politique pour les réfugiés
en disant : "Il y a le grand modèle,
c'est la Turquie.
"qui nous a menés...".
-Modèle...
-Non, mais c'est le modèle
qu'on nous vend, depuis...
Et à nous d'équilibrer
et de voir d'autres modèles,
comme on a dit :
les barrières ne sont pas
la solution, parce que finalement,
le désespoir des gens est
plus fort que les barrières,
mais d'autres politiques
de coopération,
avec des partenaires
qui sont capables, même le Maroc
vient d'entamer
une deuxième régularisation,
des migrants
qui sont chez eux.
-L'Europe tente de contrôler
ses frontières.
Il y a le système Frontex.
Est-ce qu'il s'est amélioré,
Philippe Duvin ?
-Disons les choses clairement.
Au sein des Européens, il y a
des différences d'appréciation.
Les Polonais regardent
plus vers l'Est,
l'Ukraine, la Biélorussie
et la Russie que vers le Sud.
Il y a une véritable question
de partage des préoccupations.
Et nous, les pays méditerranéens,
nous regardons vers le Sud
car notre enjeu migratoire est là.
La deuxième chose, je prends
l'exemple de la France, pardon,
mais en France, nous accueillons
300 000 personnes par an.
Nous accueillons tous les ans
l'équivalent de la ville de Nantes
qui s'installe en France :
des logements, du travail...
La question, c'est : "Peut-on encore
accueillir tous les ans
"une ville comme Nantes ?".
Je pense que non.
La vraie question,
c'est pour en sortir.
Il faut à la fois contrôler
les frontières,
Frontex, très insuffisant,
malgré ce qui a été fait récemment,
mais aussi, il faut donner
aux pays d'origine
des moyens de se développer.
Il faut leur permettre
de créer des Etats,
la paix, l'éducation, la santé.
Bref, nous avons intérêt,
nous européens, pour juguler
la vague migratoire
qui est considérable,
et elle pose des tas de problèmes,
il faut être aveugle
pour les ignorer,
il faut aider ces pays
à se développer pour que les gens
qui habitent ces pays
n'aient pas l'impression
que la solution
pour avoir une vie meilleure,
ce sont les mots employés
par le monsieur...
-Le migrant camerounais.
-"Je dois partir pour une vie
meilleure". Il faut leur dire
que la vie meilleure sera chez eux.
On ne peut plus les accueillir.
-Les politiques d'austérité
appliquées depuis 2008
ou même avant,
mais 2008 était critique,
ont fait qu'on a recoupé
dans les Etats membres
la politique de la coopération.
-C'est une erreur.
-Voilà. C'est une erreur,
mais une erreur des aveugles.
Et maintenant, on dit que...
Il faut... Ca, c'est une politique
de développement,
c'est à moyen et long terme.
Pour le moment, il faut voir
comment on fait
avec les personnes chez nous,
comment on peut les accueillir
et comment on remédie à...
-Et de les renvoyer si jamais
ils sont entrés illégalement.
-C'est prévu dans la loi.
-Ca dépend s'ils sont demandeurs
d'asile, ils ont le droit...
Et si ce sont des migrants,
il faut voir, parce qu'aussi,
on est un peu divisés,
on sait qu'il y a des rapports
depuis des années
de la commission qui dit
que notre capacité démographique
est vraiment limite, sur certaines
régions, la France, comme l'Espagne,
on est dans un dépeuplement massif.
-Il y a eu de grandes manifestions
de soutiens aux migrants en Espagne.
-Parce qu'on n'a pas réussi
à tenir nos engagements.
On avait engagé pour plus
de 17 000 réfugiés,
demandeurs d'asile,
c'est notre obligation européenne,
et on est à presque
un millier, juste.
Alors, ça,
c'est un autre élément de comment
à l'UE, les engagements
qu'ont pris les Etats membres,
leur gouvernement, après,
on est depuis deux ans,
et qu'ils n'ont pas encore engagé.
C'est des choses qu'on doit faire.
-Mme Griesbeck.
-Rendons à César ce qui est à César.
L'UE est la première pourvoyeuse
en termes d'aide au développement.
Moi, je pense
que ce qu'il faut faire,
parce qu'on est au milieu du guet,
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
accueillir autant de migrants
que ceux qui souhaiteraient venir,
qu'on doit distinguer
entre les réfugiés
et les migrants économiques,
on doit travailler
avec nos partenaires,
mais on doit aussi repositionner
l'aide au développement. Membre
des ACP,
j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller dans ces pays
Et on a l'impression
qu'il y a une grande part
de l'argent des Européens,
je risque d'être critiquée
dans ce que je dis,
mais qui part dans les sables.
Et donc, l'argent des Européens,
il doit être évalué, estimé...
-Dans les sables, où ça ?
-Il est distribué.
-Dans les sables ?
-Il faudrait...
Il faudrait évaluer...
-Surveiller l'argent ?
-Davantage encore.
-Il y aurait
des détournements ?
-C'est pas ce que je dis.
Mais moi, j'aimerais
qu'on ait plus de contrôles
et de conformité entre ce qui est
donné, ce qui est donné
pour véritablement...
..faire en sorte que les gens
aient envie de rester
sur leur territoire,
puissent donc...
..subvenir à leurs besoins,
restent chez eux.
Tous ces jeunes qui partent,
au fond, si c'était mieux chez eux,
ils resteraient chez eux.
Et juste, aussi, réévaluer
l'aide humanitaire, parce que c'est
un ensemble, un faisceau d'éléments,
qui apportent des réponses.
-Vous voulez
réagir ?
-Je voudrais
réagir parce que ce que vous dites,
c'est assez grave
et moi, je voudrais
que comme partout,
ça veut dire dans le budget,
y a aussi des parties qui sont...
..sous inspection,
dans les budgets nationaux,
dans les budgets européens,
mais on ne peut pas dire
que l'aide humanitaire ou l'aide...
Parce que l'aide humanitaire...
C'est une aide humanitaire
qui devient
à long terme parce qu'étant donné
le peu de...
-L'aide au développement.
-Et sur le développement,
il faut aussi faire la différence.
Il y a des points concrets
- je suis au contrôle budgétaire -
qu'on est en train...
..comment dire, de faire face
avec l'OLAF et tous les moyens.
Par contre, je viens de visiter
pendant une semaine la Mauritanie,
à Nouadhibou et à Nouakchott,
des projets aidés ponctuellement,
et menés par la communauté,
une fabrique pour les poissons.
Y avait plein
d'emplois comme j'ai jamais vu
dans d'autres projets.
-Ca marche, l'aide au développement.
-Quand on identifie
des projets concrets...
-Et qu'on les suit.
-Une grande mutualité...
-Y a de tout.
-Dans un grand quartier
de Nouakchott, c'était
la demande.
On écoute la demande
qui vient de la communauté.
Pas quand on impose, peut-être,
des autres projets qu'on a sur place
et parfois, c'est pas
la bonne chose.
Il faut être à l'écoute.
-A l'écoute des populations.
-Faire face
à leurs demandes ponctuelles
pour des projets que les communautés
mènent par elles-mêmes.
-Bien précis. Philippe Juvin ?
-Que l'aide au développement ait
des points positifs,
ça va de soi. Vous avez rappelé
des expériences bénéfiques.
Toutefois, force est de constater
que c'est très insuffisant.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes face
à une vague migratoire qui nécessite
un enjeu considérable et donc,
je pense qu'il faut se poser
la question de réaxer des sommes
que nous consacrons au développement
intérieur à l'Europe,
des fonds régionaux,
pour les réaxer
sur des fonds d'aide...
-Pas d'accord du tout.
Pas d'accord.
-Pardonnez-moi.
Le 2e point,
plutôt que de construire
une énième autoroute en Pologne
ou au Portugal,
ou en France, moi,
je préfère aider
à se développer des pays
qui n'ont rien,
et font en sorte que
leur population monte au nord.
Le point que je voulais souligner,
c'est celui du rapportage.
On parle du Maroc. Attention,
c'est un partenaire fiable.
Il faut l'aider
parce que le Maroc est un pays qui,
avec un effort soutenu,
a réussi à gérer et contenir
une immigration dont, disons-nous
les choses,
les Européens ne veulent pas.
Ils ne veulent pas de l'immigration.
Pardon de le dire.
Il faut aider le Maroc,
et je suis moi très inquiet
des voix discordantes qui en Europe
ne cessent de critiquer le Maroc,
un partenaire très fiable.
-Si on a des grandes ambitions
pour l'Europe, il faut un budget...
-Ni vous ni moi
ne savons créer l'argent.
-Entièrement...
-Le problème, c'est pas l'argent.
C'est la distribution
et les allocations.
-Entièrement d'accord.
Je suis...
..tout à fait en phase
avec Philippe Juvin
sur le caractère stratégique
et extrêmement important
du partenariat avec le Maroc.
Nous avons tout à faire
avec les pays du Maghreb.
C'est, en outre,
un élément très stable...
-Ajoutons l'Algérie, la Tunisie.
-Ne pas les fragiliser.
-C'est extrêmement important.
Important pour eux, pour nous.
En revanche, faire un switch
entre les fonds structurels...
-Savoir ce qu'on veut.
-..qui servent sur les territoires
dans des projets,
des microprojets, des gros projets
d'infrastructures,
de développement,
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous,
Philippe Juvin.
C'est quelque chose de
très important pour les Européens,
pour les porteurs de projets.
-On ne fera rien.
-Ben non, mais on peut y...
-L'argent, on ne l'invente pas.
On le redistribue.
-Je vous propose une solution
qui est déjà mise sur la table
depuis longtemps, travailler
aux ressources propres de l'UE.
Il y a un très bon rapport
là-dessus,
de M. Lamassoure
et qui est resté dans les tiroirs,
pas M. Lamassoure, mais le rapport.
-Merci pour M. Lamassoure.
-Ce serait de bon aloi
de le faire.
-Vous parliez de mur.
Dans ce contexte, on se rappelle
les déclarations de Donald Trump,
voulant construire un mur
avec le Mexique,
et voulant le faire payer
par les Mexicains.
En Espagne, François Hollande a tiré
à boulets rouges
sur le président américain.
-Si chaque pays était confronté
à cette situation,
qu'est-ce qui se passerait ?
On ferait des murs,
comme dans d'autres...
..pays, sur un autre continent ?
Et on demanderait à des voisins
de payer le mur ?
Et on aurait l'air de quoi ?
On ressemblerait à quoi
si l'Europe érigeait des murs
et demandait aux pays africains
de les payer ?
Ce n'est pas le modèle
que nous voulons
parce que c'est pas le bon.
Ni sur le plan moral
ni sur le plan politique.
-Lorsque vous écoutez
le président Hollande,
vous vous dites quoi ?
-Je me dis qu'il ne sait pas
ce qui se passe en Europe,
parce qu'il y a un mur
entre l'Europe, c'est-à-dire nous,
et le Maroc,
on l'a vu dans votre reportage.
Hollande est en train de dire :
"Faut pas qu'y ait de murs."
Y a un mur ! Vous voyez,
y a une sorte de volonté
de condamnation permanente morale
de ce que font les Américains.
Le pauvre, le malheureux Trump,
qui fait suffisamment
de bêtises comme ça.
-Il est terrifiant.
-Entrer, entrer...
..dans ce débat
où il n'y est pour rien,
et François Hollande,
pardon, François Hollande
n'a pas, premièrement, à critiquer
un chef d'Etat allié comme ça.
La diplomatie est faite pour ça,
avec intelligence et souplesse,
et finesse. Il ne le fait pas.
Il dit qu'il faut pas de mur,
mais y en a un !
Y a un mur !
Y a bien un mur entre l'Espagne
et le Maroc ?
-Non, y a un mur
entre Ceuta et Melilla
et le territoire marocain.
-C'est l'Espagne.
-Mais seulement parce qu'on a dû
faire face à une situation...
Justement,
c'est pas l'Europe.
-Ah bon,
c'est pas l'Europe ?
-Parce que la politique
d'immigration n'est pas européenne.
C'est ça, le problème.
-C'est l'Europe.
-C'était à ce moment-là,
depuis 2001, on était seuls,
la commission vient
de nous le reconnaître.
On a fait face à des arrivées.
-D'accord.
-Personne en Europe a pensé
que c'était la situation.
-Je ne prétends pas
que c'est pas bien, mais il y a
un mur.
-Mais on n'est pas...
Mon parti n'est pas d'accord.
-Je sais.
-Non, il a demandé la réaction.
-Il y a encore un mur plus terrible.
La mer.
-Tout à l'heure, j'ai vu le mur.
-La mer, c'est pas un mur ?
-Bien entendu !
C'est un mur !
-Là où meurent beaucoup plus
de gens que dans...
On est contre.
-Les hommes ont construit un mur.
-L'Europe n'est pas
dans la politique de migration,
jusqu'à maintenant.
-Les Européens ont construit
un mur. Voilà.
-Nathalie Griesbeck ?
-Moi, je ne veux pas
d'une Europe forteresse,
mais je veux d'une Europe qui sache
protéger et sache éviter
les tragédies des naufrages.
D'où la nouvelle Frontex,
M. Juvin a dit
que c'était pas parfait,
en attendant,
c'est un pas en avant
et c'est même un pas
très communautaire,
puisque le système est européen.
Il n'est plus à chaque Etat.
Le chef d'Etat actuel
français est totalement décalé
dans son propos.
On a l'impression qu'il est pas
dans le temps réel.
Et si c'est pour se positionner
par rapport à Trump,
Trump, ça doit, nous les Européens,
nous inviter à rebondir,
à refonder l'Europe,
chaque jour qui passe
ou chaque nuit qui passe,
il y a une nouvelle annonce
terrifiante iconoclaste...
Plus que jamais
nous devons annoncer.
-Dans ce contexte
de montée du populisme...
Dans ce contexte de montée
du populisme, Marine Le Pen
a donné une conférence de presse
où elle s'attaque directement
à l'UE. On écoute l'eurodéputée
et candidate à l'élection
présidentielle en France.
-Voyez comme le Brexit,
l'élection de Donald Trump
et la montée de l'Europe
contre l'Union,
prétendument européenne,
qui l'étouffe,
ouvrent le 21e siècle
sur une insurrection des peuples.
Les Français savent
que leur richesse
première est la France,
sa frontière,
sa personnalité singulière et forte,
comme leur nation, sa frontière et
sa personnalité sont la 1re richesse
de tous les peuples libres
en Europe et dans le monde.
-Ces propos de Marine Le Pen
contre l'UE qui étoufferait
l'Europe, ça vous inspire quoi ?
-Marine Le Pen, d'abord, pense
qu'en construisant des murs
de plus en plus hauts,
elle va régler le problème
de l'immigration.
C'est pas comme ça que ça marche.
Elle est profondément patriote,
je le suis aussi,
nous les sommes aussi.
Ce n'est pas au moment
où le monde se divise
que nous avons intérêt,
les Européens, à nous diviser.
Nous pensons
que la France,
pardon madame la représentante
du peuple espagnol,
a une chance de peser
dans les affaires du monde
si elle est associée
à d'autres pays européens.
Nous pensons qu'on est plus forts
à plusieurs.
Y a des tas de choses
qui marchent pas bien.
Frontex, c'est très insuffisant.
Mais dire que nous allons
nous en sortir en étant tout seuls,
les Français, c'est absurde.
Ca ne peut pas marcher.
-D'ailleurs,
lundi prochain à Versailles,
un sommet à quatre :
France, Allemagne, Espagne, Italie.
C'est quoi, une Europe
à plusieurs vitesses ?
Inés Ayala Sender ?
-Pour le moment,
on a le débat sur l'eurozone
- et comment dire ? -
comment avancer sur un sujet
de justement avoir plus d'Europe
ou moins d'Europe,
parce que là,
je suis absolument avec vous.
L'Espagne a toujours été
plus européiste,
justement, depuis la mort de Franco.
Justement parce que l'Europe
signifiait la démocratie
et fermait la porte
à la tyrannie, à la dictature.
-La dictature franquiste.
-Pour nous, l'Europe,
c'est cette capacité
de faire ensemble
et dans la situation
régionale actuelle mondiale
et globale,
où on est plus forts ensemble,
franchement,
revenir sur la renationalisation,
de laquelle on souffre
depuis l'année 2000 ou un peu avant,
je trouve que c'est complètement...
..ne pas comprendre
les enjeux "globals".
-Nathalie Griesbeck ?
-Madame Le Pen,
elle surfe sur les fragilités,
sur les difficultés sociales
et économiques.
-Les peurs, les mensonges.
-C'est quelque chose...
-On dit ça depuis longtemps.
-..de méprisable ce qu'elle fait.
-C'est surtout efficace.
-Elle est à 25 % d'intentions
de votes.
-On va être nombreux...
-Suffisant, comme réponse ?
-Ca veut dire qu'il faut bouger,
qu'il faut créer
des politiques communes,
de défense, pour commencer, et là,
ça démarre, d'investissements
de long terme, une politique d'asile
qui soit commune
et qui soit solide,
parce qu'unis, on est plus forts.
-Consolider aussi l'emploi.
-Je reprends
la France. La France,
c'est 1 % de la population du monde.
Comment voulez-vous
que les Français répondent
aux défis et menaces ?
-Merci en tout cas à vous trois
d'avoir accepté,
ce sera le mot de la fin,
d'être venus débattre avec nous.
Merci à vous de nous avoir suivis.
C'est la fin d'"Europe hebdo".
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine.
Même endroit, même heure. Bye bye !
SOUS-TITRAGE : ERICSSON
(générique)
---